Speaker 1: All right. We may have gotten
some information about this very strange,
unexplained trip to Washington, D.C., that
Donald Trump made Sunday night. Yesterday,
we reported on some of the speculation that this
may be because Trump is getting arrested or maybe
Trump is having some kind of medical appointment
in Washington, D.C. or whatnot. The new I don't
know that it's necessarily the consensus, but the
way things are pointing is that Donald Trump flew
up to D.C. to go to his Virginia golf club to meet
with lawyers and aides on the golf course to avoid
the potential surveillance and media scrutiny
that could take place if such a meeting actually
happened at a lawyer's office. And, of course,
the lawyers that he is currently meeting with,
believed to be believed to be related to criminal
defense that Donald Trump may need if indeed he is
indicted. So let's go through what we know at this
point. Business Insider reporting Trump spotted at
his Virginia golf course after video of him on
a flight to the D.C. area sparked a firestorm
of speculation. Now, the big component about this
is that Donald Trump was on the golf course and we
have a video of it with no golf clubs. Clearly not
playing golf. And so this was the start of, well,
what is what is the point of this? What's going
on here? Is this sort of a mobster like meeting
where Donald Trump is getting away from media
and possible surveillance or whatever else the
case may be? And you see Trump driving
around in a golf cart. He's not golfing.
There is no golf clubs whatsoever. And a number
of people who know Trump, by the way, just
Trump going around in a golf cart. There's
something just kind of funny, absurd about it.
This video was shot at quite a distance, by
the way. So all sorts of different speculation
and questions add to what this is about. Michael
Cohen, friend of The David Pakman Show and former
Trump lawyer who knows Trump very, very well, has
a very good tweet thread about this where he says,
Many are asking me why Mr. Mushroom Putter was at
his D.C. golf course, which is really in Virginia,
he says, to play golf. My sources say he was
meeting with two lawyers in secrecy and didn't
trust being at their offices. Notice there are
no clubs on the cart. No golf clubs on the cart.
Glad that Drudge found this tweet both newsworthy
and humorous for his readers to enjoy. Yeah. So
that's Michael Cohen's perspective. And indeed,
when you look, there are no golf clubs there.
We then have a hole. Then there was another one,
which I have. No, there was that. That is the one.
So this seems to basically be the most logical
explanation at this point in time if Donald Trump
did it. Media follows and covers Trump to the
degree that they are able to and informed to know
where he's going. So we know the trip to D.C. was
unannounced. That doesn't mean it was necessarily
unplanned. It might have been planned at the
last minute and media were not told about it.
If Donald Trump had ended up at Walter Reed or at
some kind of medical center, it would be known it
would have become news. And so this now is the
most likely explanation, which is Trump paranoid
Trump surveillance, concerned Trump or whatever
it is you want to say wanted to meet with people
outside of the range of whatever it was
that he was paranoid about. And it all
is believed to be related to Donald
Trump's need for criminal lawyers.
As we potentially get closer and closer to an
indictment. Now let's talk a little bit about the
indictment. As is often the case, we saw this with
Matt Gaetz and this is ongoing with Matt Gaetz.
There is a search warrant. There is news of an
investigation and then there is no indictment
immediately or whatever. And people start
e-mailing me and asking questions about, well,
when is the indictment coming? And when it
comes to the Trump indictment, it is completely
plausible that we are still months from such an
indictment. If one is coming, it takes a long time
to complete these investigations. And again,
there's still an if as to whether Trump is going
to get indicted. I can only assume based
on the amount of seriousness and planning
with which the search warrant was approved on
Trump, FBI approval, attorney general approval
of judge signature, all of the things
that must be done that have to be done.
When you are doing something like this with a
former president, I can only imagine that it's
going to take more than the few weeks that
remain between now and the midterm election
for final decisions to be made about
charging or not charging. Trump What
would be in that indictment? And there
is also a there are some reports that
the charges would not be made before the election
to avoid the appearance of of people trying to
have political influence. I actually think that
it's less likely that that's the explanation
and it's more likely that it just takes time to
put charges like this together. We will follow it.